bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fuori j
oggi andiamo avanti su scriver nahles
unlimited prima di cominciare vorrei
soltanto provare una cosa da gad ora
innanzi tutto nello scorso episodio
abbiamo fatto vedere lo slider man band
hermen però stavolta è leggermente
diverso da ok lo slider bene gay è
leggermente diverso dall'ultima volta
che l'avete visto perché diciamo questo
e quello fatto bene io il parlamento ho
provato provato a farlo e mi è riuscito
anche abbastanza male comunque
vabbè buttiamolo via era soltanto per
farvi vedere che quello dell'altra volta
era lo slider modalità beta ecco è
invece come seconda novità oltre allo
slider man abbiamo anche la banana mobil
banana mobile non mobile va bene non
importa che ho creato e sarà il nostro
mezzo di locomozione
da adesso in avanti in in scrive l'ansa
al limite come potete vedere alle ruote
ma non non girano salta non mi chiedete
perché anche l'ombrello diciamo
rimovibile per i giorni di pioggia i
giorni di sole serve comunque per tutte
le utility con tutti i gadget vi viene a
costare meno di una smart comunque vabbè
lasciamo dimenticava una volta che si
smonta lascia una mini banana che corre
in giro a selvatica non mi chiedete
perché quindi dopo queste due novità
raga direi che possiamo partire eravamo
rimasti che siamo in un castello credo
una roba del genere ci sono degli orchi
e c'è un cavaliere che non ci fa passare
allora dammi qualcosa per investire gli
orchi facciamo non sono il medioevo un
carro armato va benissimo coi bestie
il tuo contatori frammenti di salette
diventa un rosso se uno qualsiasi di
frammenti diventa imprendibile presente
a livello che è successo a noi ha
sottratto di avvertimento perché
effettivamente ce l'ho fatto ok
comandante di carro prima sfida
completata non avevo ancora completate
forse di sfida e adesso valori dai carlo
che mi serve perfetto grazie
andiamo noi c'è un carro armato nel
medioevo cioè questo non ha senso la
gara ci siano dei delle balle di fieno
che non so che cosa servono va bè noi
smontiamo ok di sotto di sopra dove
andiamo non so veramente albo andiamo a
chi è questo dammi qualcosa per far
divertire il re direi raga pistola
pistola ad acqua se riesco ok fanno
divertire fa ridere e difficile sì certo
la pista la l'acqua nel medioevo
ora puoi utilizzare il fratello di
maxwell e fratello di maxwell diciamo
che sono ma ci ha dato dentro in poche
parole
vabbè dettagli a parte c'è re che
sicuramente vorrà qualcosa se non la
reggina non so no invece non vuole un
cazzo strano si vede che sa già tutto
non lo so perché ma non vuole niente
vabbè c'è la reggina ecco perché non
voleva niente mi sembra giusto odio
questo vestito con rush dammi qualcosa
di più elegante da mettere va bene
allora direi una tuta da astronauta ok
mettiti questo va beh noi facciamo finta
di niente andiamo avanti questore
qualcosa no mi dimentico sempre che per
vedere se c'è qualcuno che vuole
qualcosa basta premere da sarah hicks
ma non importa sono cose
che posso anche dimenticarmi oddio c'e
robin hood perché darci delle armi per
eliminare gli invasori
allora facciamo vede arco facciamo sto
punto diamo gli archos empi arco
architettura non sport bike o lo sport
ok sono diventati dice mio dio cosa
accaduto che cazzo è caduto mi serve un
paracadute paracadute ok
devo andare sotto a vedere che cazzo è
successo vai
ok sono anche caduto in testa c'era una
persona c'era sono riuscito a cadere lì
in testa ok è però non c'è nessuno di
sotto va bene si vede che si sono
smaterializzati comunque mi fa piacere è
caduto col paracadute non ci speravo che
funzionasse sinceramente ad ora c'è il
piccone andiamo a tipo in minecraft a
trovare i diamanti adesso c'è anche la
pala perfetto e che cosa dovrei fare qui
c'è qualcuno che dorme scansafatiche
il cavaliere comatoso facciamo sveglia
sveglia
ok alzate e ora rialzarsi ma dove vai
non sta andando non voglio saperlo
andiamo avanti allora concetti po prince
of persia c'è un tipo maxwell l'anti
marzo e il tipo quello dei fantagenitori
darci qualcosa per far evadere il nostro
compagno allora facciamo tipo alla alla
oblivion o skyrim grimaldello
grimaldello cosa ho scritto io
sicuramente qualcosa di sbagliato vai
apre ok fuga dalle segrete adesso centro
io se non mi dispiace no
riempie ti riempi o rinchiuso un piccone
fantastico per ogni tanto c'è il machete
ok andiamo ad assassinare qualcosa sta
roba trementina non mi chiedete che
cos'è vabbè torniamo su cosa dovrei fare
qui i ragazzi preciso che non c'è un
presente allora c'è un'asta wright che
devo prendere ma non so qual è la st
wright e ho controllato già tutto no beh
per forza non ho controllato tutto se
non avrei già preso allora c'è noli
sopra comincia arrivo intanto il
paracadute per scendere dalle scale mi
sembra d'obbligo a ce l'ha se la
sinistra non l'ho visto che hai faccio
tipo ezio se sui tetti
ok il paracadute torna utile in tutte le
situazioni o che già la st wright però
prima di prenderla voglio provare a
vedere che cosa dovrei fare qui c'è il
boia
cosa devo fare c'è qualcuno che ha
bisogno di aiuto se aiutami a salvare
mio amico ma non uccidere nessuno
questo è senza dubbio un lavoro per jack
sparrow però jack spasso cos'è questo e
jack sparso
ok gex falso scoop pensaci tu salvaro
salva una vita innocente
cosa sta facendo
allora jack sparso è una persona inutile
abbiamo capito è il boia si sta no no no
no no no il boia si sta incassando
quindi muoviamoci
come faccio a salvare mia mykonos o
supereroe questo punto penso supereroe
buono buono buono buono vai vai vai
salverò perfetto cosa che succede
ok
che cazzo è successo mi ha lasciato una
ok mi ha lasciato un naso e baffi finti
non mi chiedete perché non dà veramente
come scelta era fantastica comunque
grazie per aver salvato la giornata
adesso non servi più
e direi di andare direttamente sulla
starai tasto punto aiuta a far crescere
una lucertola per farla diventare il
terrore del regno
va beh noi iniziamo non so che cosa può
significare sta roba per ora perde il
drago orfano sono un fabbro devo
fabbricare letteralmente una lucertola
questa piccola lucertola aspira a
diventare un grosso imponente drago m
ordinaria scrivi qualcosa per assegnarli
dei poteri magici ok questa è una
lucertola dei poteri magici let there be
light l'uso andiamo buratto lussuosa
lattea
cos'è cosa ho appena fatto cosa ho
appena creato mio dio va bene dei poteri
magici bacchetta magica una lucertola
con la bacchetta magica bacchetta magica
magia
ok by ok casa invasata che è successo si
è voluto tipo in pokémon raga il
prossimo e charlize hard credo vabbè è
un drop di fuoco dargli qualcosa
affinché abbia un potente alito di fuoco
direi lista rain ok
facciamo un collutorio del bello potente
però eh va beh direi che non funziona
allora un alito di fuoco bello potente e
allora l'annuncia fiamme lanciafiamme
ok perfetto il lanciafiamme e stato
scelsero ficca nella gola e poi ok siamo
anche siamo a cia richard ragazze much
arisa il prossimo vabbè basta con le
evoluzioni dei pokemon mi sento ridicolo
adesso al drago metti una persona nella
gabbia indra in grado di opporsi al
drago di fuoco ok dovahkiin miu miu
benedetto cosa dovrei creare chi è
qualcuno che addestrato a combattere con
il fuoco
ma perché
ma perché mi date un perché mangiafuoco
dovrebbe sfidare un drago vabbè ha fatto
una bella fine tra l'altro facciamo
proviamo a raggiungere un aggettivo
facciamo vivo
ok è tornato in vita risurrezione dello
scheletro ok
ebbene il mangiafuoco diciamo che tutto
sto casino è servito per far perdere un
po di peso al mangiafuoco comunque che
sarete questa tra l'altro amico il drago
e il dragone completato la nona siamo
già la nonna starai tragga tre episodi
direi che buono dai non so bene come non
so veramente se sto andando veloce o no
però dai diciamo che buona
e intanto cuoce della gente a caso e
direi che posso cambiare poco che i
ragazzi abbiamo finito qui quasi tutto e
vabbè poi magari più avanti
oddio c'è un quale paracadute vero se
magari più avanti quando finirò
quando solo verso la fine del gioco
vedrò se riesco a finire anche tutte le
mini sfide nel frattempo vediamo di
cambiare zona
vediamo se riesco a cambiare zona
andiamo su una zona che non ci sono
ancora andato ovviamente quindi tipo
questa la meta foresta
prima di farlo soltanto una cosa ragazzi
spiegate perchè ci einstein con un
cappello da cuoco c'è ma che cazzo di
senso ha non s cosa vuoi allora il mio è
fatto noi così buon'ora per trovare
tartufi ma inventati qualcosa a sto
punto mica sei un genio
allora facciamo un cane un cane a caso
mai è proprio portatile è proprio un
cane portatile cento va in giro lo usi
tipo metal detector mai così trovami
tartufi e vabbè spero che tu sia
contento è uno scienziato con un
cappello da cuoco è fantastico
nel caso mi servirà qualche consiglio ti
chiamerò intanto sei albert quindi ti
conosco andiamo nel maniero
il maniero grave ok lo siamo perché c'è
la maschera di ghostface questa barra
riporta in vita le cose vogliamo raga
vampiro a sto punto
ok vai perfetto da ok sotterrato vivo
non funziona la vacca vacca vacca
proprio portiamo in vita le vacche
cosa devo fare il becchino adesso che
hai creato un bel vampiro
bene bene bene vedetevela voi io me ne
vado tu il vampiro e la vacca
io posso fidarmi nel camino
evidentemente sì c'è un ok manca rianima
mi ok ci provo def il defibrillatore per
rianimare una statua o che vai libera
c'è è vivo
c'è ancora ma che faccia ci fa qui
allora è no da domandato allora per
sfuggire ai vampiri si inventa di tutto
senti non è che mi fai fare una
cavalcata adesso che ci sei no no no ok
sto chiedendo e via col defibrillatore
mi fa piacere che riporta in vita alle
statue direi di andare c'è uno strike
qui sì vieni più vicino per attivati o
che dire che devo fare il giro perfetto
andiamo chi sono questi ci piacerebbe
avere qualcosa con cui giocare allora
andiamo su qualcosa di veloce perché
devo andare a prendere la sarai facciamo
una roba abbastanza piccola che so
montagne russe giusto per vai
divertitevi perfetto non siete non vi
piacciono le montagne russe
se siete gli unici bambini a cui non
ok allora facciamo non lo so
bambola allora vediamo se con la bambola
siete bambola di plastica di pezza che
ne sono uguale vai vi divertite
cosa è successo vieni a giocare con noi
non ci tengo riesce a vedere la tua
immagine riflessa no perché manca no
perché non è uno specchio riflettente
allora facciamo riflettente
ok adesso se il cervello con il bacio di
max del tipo l'anti cosmo
beh ve l'avevamo fatto benissimo radio
quale ok cos'è questa mi vuoi dare una
cosa una cosa stai facendo oddio sta
creando della roba a casa cosa mi ha
creato che cosa c'è sta creando della
roba kasami foto tocca ad air nostro
punto se va beh noi andiamo su raga il
portale non so che cosa mi serve
i ragni no i ragni no i ragni no i ragli
no di ragni no coccodrillo vai
mangiatelo vai vinci cos'è cos'è brutto
stronzo devi difendermi
ok mi6 bastato poi così chi sono sti due
sono i bambini di prima solo che sono
soltanto disegnati no adesso sono ok non
voglio fare domande non mi interessa
andiamo su come faceva arrivare la sua
ragazza e mi serve probabilmente una
scala perché se no non ci arrivo allora
facciamo ali e facciamo le ali no ma
scala è troppo semplice
vai così ok siamo arrivati alla st
wright trovi i fantasmi e liberali ok
raga faccio l'ultima missione per oggi
ok cacciatore di fantasmi libera la casa
dei fantasmi che la in festa non l'hai a
marzo e qualcosa per vedere gli esseri
soprannaturali
cos'è che avevano quelli di ghostbusters
non mi ricordo è un aspirapolvere
succhia fantasmi su cosa fantasia aspira
ok vai così siamo potenti io direi
allora invece dell'aspirapolvere
facciamo occhiali a raggi ics raga più
che occhiali a raggi ics mi sembrano
degli occhiali in 3d però con questi
potrò vedere i fantasmi
oddio raga scribblenauts è diventato
veramente in 3d ma veramente che figo
non raga ma vedo tutti in 3d c'è raga
veramente se avete degli occhiali 3d
provate il secondo a metterli perché non
non so se c'è se funziona dovrebbe
funzionare in teoria ok con questo sono
in grado di vedere i fantasmi non mi
chiedete perché e andiamo lì sopra ok ti
vedo dammi tre cose con cui giocare me
ne andrò da questa casa allora dildo
dardo dardo va bene lo stesso gioca con
questo poi gioca con facciamo una fionda
a caso proprio la prima cosa che mi è
venuto in mente ok è come un uomo come
ultima cosa pollo di gomma ok gioca col
polo di gomma e divertiti e adesso si è
materializzato un altro fantasma ok
perfetto allora devo trovare la roba non
mi ricordo che filmerà dove dove
ritrovare le cose
c'è un film comunque dove praticamente
dovevi dare delle cose dei fantasmi per
farli divertire
allora non lascerò la casa finché non
avrò un matrimonio che ha sempre
desiderato allora la sposa cadavere ma
facciamo non lo so uno sposo cadaver
altro non mi sposo cadaverica e vai
siete perfetti insieme che bella coppia
ragazzi e adesso cosa vuoi
dammi tre il matrimonio che sempre da
midas i tre cose per liberarmi allora ci
vuole anche un prete cadavere
tutti i cadaveri cadaveri cadaverico
cadaverica prete cadaverica ok allora
adesso mi manca soltanto l'anello è poi
mi sposo io dai papà poi baciare la
sposa
ok no veramente la compito del prete ma
io ho potuto lavoro perfetto infatti
pretese come vedete s'è incazzato e
vabbè andiamo anche da lui ho bisogno di
qualcuno a sposare adesso mi chiedono
sono rimasti intrappolati per cui qui
per troppo tempo da 1300 le righe della
sacra chiese potrò andarmene ma che
cazzo vuole questo sacro graal oggi
acceleramento ma che cazzo ok
prendi a vale doppio il sacro graal vale
doppio giustamente ma se facevo dio che
cosa mi dà
di questa raga io lasci mai con dio
tutto è pazzo fini rappresenta perché
c'è dio scrive loud ce l'abbiamo fatta
ce l'abbiamo fatta raga ok la raccolta
cacciatore di fantasmi completato totale
sarà it 12 direi che posso fermare noi
livelli sbloccati vai da lily va beh lo
è ci andrò nel prossimo episodio ho
sbloccato nuovi livelli quindi nuove
zone
niente raga direi che chiudo qui perché
anche perché tardi come al solito se vi
è piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e trovate
come al solito in ogni mio video nella
descrizione se non siete ancora i siti
iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo a un prossimo
video bella ragazzi
[Musica]